-I know it's your favorite job,
but you also told me
it's the most dangerous job
you ever did.
-Yeah.
So many accidents.
I got chased by bees,
hit by a car, season 1.
Got a concussion
during season 1
because I saw a cookie
on the ground,
and I was like --
I have a 30-day rule.
And I was like,
"I'm gonna...
I'm gonna eat
that cookie."
And I just reached, forcefully,
to go and get the cookie,
and knocked myself out
on my side table.
Had a concussion. Had seizures
for, like, three months.
I...
I rolled my ankle.
I broke my arm.
None of which was on set,
just during filming.
And then, finally,
we had a giant action scene
in season 3, where we have to
fight all these demons.
And they gave every single
other character --
including 70-year-old Ted --
action to do,
and made me just sit behind
a pool table, and watch,
because they said it was
the only thing I was safe doing.
At the end of this
three-day shoot
of me crouching behind
a pool table,
I pull a muscle in my ass
while down there,
and remain the only member
of the cast
who sustained an injury.
-You were supposed to be safe.
[ Both laugh ]
And they're all
doing action?
-Yeah. They're, like, fighting
with pool cues, and everything.
I did nothing, and broke my ass.
-Oh, that's not good.